we live in a world saturated with
misinformation so it's no surprise that
we get things wrong from time to time
sit back and find out all the false
things you've come to believe
about why these shows were cancelled
years after felicity left the airwaves
it still remembered for one event
the haircut more than any character plot
point or storyline felicity's iconic
hair getting trimmed into a weird sort
of pixie cut has defined
the series it's been a source of pop
culture derision
ever since and it's often considered the
moment that killed the show
there is a little truth to this being
that there was enough fan backlash that
executive producer jj
abrams took responsibility for the idea
in the press
however the real problems were changing
time slots
and weaker stories first the time slot
felicity was broadcast on tuesday
evenings during the first season
prime tv real estate for the late 90s
the second season saw the network move
it to sunday night
a much weaker time slot second the story
lines were underwhelming an opinion held
by both fans
and creatives working on the show abrams
admitted this at the time to the
pittsburgh post gazette
saying there was a crucial period of
four or five episodes where we told
stories that were a little
unfocused and it didn't feel as
compelling as it should have
his estimate of four or five is
important because the haircut
happened in episode five it might have
shocked
some fans but the show was already
losing viewers
and it's easier to blame a single event
than a series of bad decisions
the final season of zoe 101 was shown
under the specter
of one of nickelodeon's biggest
controversies
star jamie lynn spears becoming pregnant
at age 16.
given that she announced her pregnancy
in december of 2007
and the fourth and final season began
january 2008
many see the two events and assume one
led to the finale
of the other this is false the two
events were in fact
independent of one another series
creator dan schneider gets asked if
spears pregnancy led to the end of the
show
quite a bit so much so that he put the
answer on his blog's faq page
he made it abundantly clear that they
didn't even find out she was pregnant
until later
the last season was shot during the
summer of 2007
and wrapped in august we had our final
wrap party at the end of august
everyone had a fun time hugged and we
all said our goodbyes that was the end
of zoe 101 in terms of production
it wasn't until several weeks later in
october that anyone from our production
heard about jamie lynn being pregnant
he also said that the show ended because
nick had enough in the can for reruns
and everyone was ready to move on
one of the central narratives nbc pushed
in the wake of the 2010 tonight show
conflict was that conan o'brien's run
as the host of the show led to the
long-running franchise losing money for
the first time
in its history somehow despite all the
public examination
and re-litigation this point has stood
here's the thing though
it's mathematically improbable for the
show to have lost money
[Music]
[Applause]
for starters television isn't about
having the most viewers it's about
having the right viewers
while o'brien's tonight was drawing
fewer overall viewers he outperformed
leno's tenure and key demographics a
surefire sign of better ad buys and high
revenue
speaking of revenue lower revenue
doesn't mean unprofitable
o'brien's tonight had similar ratings to
the late show with david letterman
a show that cost more and was still
profitable o'brien's salary was
also estimated to be just half of leno's
30 million dollars
on top of all this talk shows are so
durable because they're among the
cheapest television shows to produce
and the idea that the biggest named show
in late night would lose money
is unlikely o'brien told 60 minutes that
nbc's claim about tonight losing money
was impossible
a sentiment echoed by late night experts
and experts consulted by the rap
o'brien reasoned in bill carter's book
the war for late night that
nbc could have only decided the show was
unprofitable if they factored in
construction of new offices and sets
which is a stretch to say the least
strangers with candy frequently appears
on list of shows cancelled too soon
running for 30 episodes between 1999 and
2000
the show had a murderous row of comedic
talent amy sedaris stephen colbert
paul dinello and janine garofalo and a
strong
cult following fans rejoiced when a
prequel film came out in 2005 starring
all the original cast
during the press store sedaris revealed
something that didn't get much attention
then nor has it since the show was never
cancelled at all
in an interview with the austin
chronicle sedera stated that at no point
was the show ever cancelled
we wanted to go out we wanted a final
episode because usually comedy central
does
things in three seasons so we kind of
figured we had three seasons
we thought if we were going to do it
again yeah we could write 10 episodes or
not write 10 episodes
they just stopped making episodes
figuring that their time
was up anyway the wonder years came to a
natural conclusion
both in the show's continuity and with
real life circumstances
in the show kevin and winnie's
relationship comes to a passionate close
and everyone is ready to move on to
their next chapter
in real life all the young actors were
getting older and the show had to wrap
up sooner
rather than later but according to at
least one source these aren't the true
reasons the show ended the blame lies
with a lawsuit
my hunch was that my father would not
let being called a brainwashed [ __ ] at
his dinner table go by
unremarked during the final season the
show's former costume designer monique
long
filed a sexual harassment suit against
stars fred savage and jason herbie
claiming she was let go from the show
after rebuffing their advances
abby mills who played norma arnold
revealed in a 2018
interview with yahoo entertainment that
the pr nightmare that would have
resulted
led the show to make the final episode
of that season the series finale
instead of hanging on for another year
mills refuted the suit which was later
settled out of court
savage has long defended his innocence
but long stands by her claims
either way there's credible reason to
believe this legal action had more to do
with the show getting axed than savage
turning 17.
the arc of twin peaks as a show from
debut
to cancellation is often summed up
thusly the first season was a smash hit
the network forced the show to reveal
the killer early after dwindling
interest and the rest of season 2 just
wasn't that good
every part of this is at least partially
true and there were other factors that
fed into it such as a behind the scenes
feud that killed the planned audrey
cooper storyline but this all leaves out
maybe the most
important reason for the ratings drop
time slot shenanigans
the first episode of twin peaks
broadcast on a sunday
nabbed monster ratings partially due to
america's funniest home videos being the
lead in
ratings stayed solid enough after it
moved to thursdays but there was a clear
decline in viewership
after four episodes this was due in part
to abc's scheduling twin peaks against
cheers a well-established powerhouse of
a show
cheers was also episodic instead of
serialized like twin peaks
meaning that someone who missed an
episode of twin peaks might be more
willing to cut their losses in an
era before dvr the situation was made
worse in season two
being that it was moved to saturday
nights one of the worst time slots on
all of tv
series co-creator mark frost brought up
another obstacle during an interview on
wfdu
which was that the show kept getting
preempted by coverage of the gulf war
a huge moneymaker and ratings getter for
tv at the time
between the bad time slot the preemption
and the serialization in an era when
that wasn't common the show was going to
lose viewers regardless of its content
the 1980s dungeons and dragons cartoon
came out at the initial height of the
game's popularity
and was a big hit for a few seasons it
also attracted controversy
almost entirely because dnd was one of
the targets of the 1980 satanic panic
the most prominent of these objections
came from the national coalition of
television violence who petitioned that
the federal trade commission and
consumer protection agency to put a
warning on all dnd
properties including the tv show that
they were linked to violent deaths
these requests were rejected between the
dnd panic and the concerns about
violence
the fact that the show ended with an
unresolved storyline after three seasons
fed into two rumors about its
cancellation both of them
false first that the missing episodes
showed the kids suffering an awful fate
often listed
as being stuck in hell after dying
scriptwriter michael reeves shot this
down hard on his blog
second that the show is cancelled after
protests mark avenir who developed the
show for television dismissed that on
his blog
explaining the dungeons and dragon
series was cancelled due to declining
ratings
i keep reading stories about it getting
yanked off the air because it was too
violent
or because protest groups thought it was
satanic or something of the sort
as far as i know the protests were
minimal and had no
impact the show simply began losing its
audience as all shows eventually do
good but make sure you wait until i fire
the signal arrow before you begin your
attack
the mirror phrase cousin oliver inspires
snarled lips and looks of disdain among
sitcom lovers
brought in during the last season of the
brady bunch oliver was meant to replace
some of the cute factor that was lost
after the youngest kids grew up but
instead ended up
a cloying presence none of this is a
knock on actor robbie wrist who was just
a kid and went on to have a solid career
in music
and voice acting nonetheless cousin
oliver is now shorthand for when shows
bring in someone cute to liven up a
dying show and the new character
ends up having the inverse effect
there's just one problem with that
theory the brady bunch was not popular
during its original run
not by any meaningful metric though the
show surely had its regular viewers at
no point during its five-season run did
it crack the top 30 of nielsen ratings
peaking at 31
in season 3. the final season was rated
55th
out of a possible 80 shows and at that
point no
cast addition or subtraction is going to
make a difference
and it's unfair to blame a kid albeit an
obnoxious one who was only there for a
handful of episodes
there's also a decent chance abc
wouldn't have wanted to continue anyway
not only were the kids getting older
they had enough episodes for syndication
if so that plan worked beautifully it
became a monster hit in tv stable and
re-runs
never leaving the air and kick-starting
a new franchise
the phrase jump the shark has a special
meaning to happy days fans
named after an absurd stunt in season 5
episode
hollywood part 3 where fonzie straps on
water skis and jumps over a shark the
idiom refers to the point where a show
does something that marks a decline
in quality for happy days in particular
the shark jump wasn't even close to the
beginning of the end
it wasn't even the beginning of the
middle it ran for years
afterwards happy days was never a
critical darling so the idea that
reviews went down afterwards is hard to
substantiate
also the phrase jumped the shark was
coined circa 1985
at least one year after happy days ended
and nearly a decade
after the episode in question having
such a moment marked in hindsight
instead of contemporarily shows this as
more of a thought experiment than a hard
and fast rule
the franchise also had a number of
important events occur
after the jump including the
introduction of mark from orc
and a half dozen spin-offs fred fox jr
who wrote the episode made an airtight
point in the la times
it was the 91st episode and the fifth
season
if this was really the beginning of a
downward spiral
why did the show stay on the air for six
more seasons and shoot an additional 164
episodes
why did we rank among the top 25 in five
of those six seasons
me tv even offered their own list of
more accurate alternatives
including fonzie working as a teacher
and kissing a nun
television in the 1950s and 60s were
defined by
shows taking place in rural areas and
small towns
green acres petticoat junction the
beverly hillbillies and more than a few
shows about the town of mayberry ruled
the airwaves and that's just scratching
the
surface then there was a sea change
around 1970
when networks saw urban shows like all
in the family
and mary tyler moore draw great ratings
and bring a new level of respectability
and sophistication to the networks
by the end of the 1970 and 1971 tv
season most of these country-themed
shows were unceremoniously cancelled in
what's been dubbed
the rural purge one such show that
wrapped during this era was gomer pyle
usmc
and given its connection to mayberry is
often incorrectly listed as getting
cancelled as part of the world perch
this is false being that star jim nabors
left the show in 1969 after five wildly
successful seasons simply because he
wanted to do something else
neighbors saw himself as more of an
entertainer than an actor and as such he
built a variety show
after departing there was however one
related show that got axed
mayberry rfd the last connection to the
andy griffith show remaining
it's likely mayberry rfd and gomer pyle
usmc
got conflated and a misconception was
born
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one